news daily from science mission to
determine the role of dimerization of
vitamin A in lipofuscin accumulation
prior to the retinal diseases authors in
the journal PNAS replaced hydrogen atoms
at c 20 on vitamin A with the deuterium
which inhibited vitamin E dimerization
this resulted in reduced lipofuscin and
transcriptional normalization of genes
associated with inflammation without
compromising retinal function thus
confirming the role of vitamin E a
dimerization in retinal diseases next
scientist in the journal Nature
communications show that high fiber
consumption leads to the changes in
microbiota and small fatty acid
production acetate enters the
bloodstream and inhibits hdacs leading
to transcription of Fox p3 first p3
promotes track numbers and functions
which suppresses airway inflammation
small fatty acids also enter filters and
provides protection to the lungs in a
similar fashion for more news visitors
at www science mission com more science
mission facebook page